last 42 years that's a huge minimum
sentence and the judge making it clear
that she had considered the possibility
of giving cashmen a whole life sentence
but um decided not to because she had to
accept that he had not intended to kill
Olivia
a whole life sentence she might have
given to him for the premeditated murder
of a gun murder of a child but it was
clear to everybody throughout the
hearing that his Target was somebody
else he was chasing another criminal
Joseph knee and had intended to kill him
so the judge making it very clear that
it was a fine line but she did give him
if you like the benefit of the doubt so
he's got a minimum 42 years which means
that he will be 76 before he's got any
chance of being released that will be
his first opportunity to ask for parole
and I guess a lot of people might think
that perhaps effectively
that is a whole life sentence and she
did make it clear as judges always do in
these circumstances that even at the end
of 42 years uh there would be no
guarantee that he would be freed
um she summed it up towards the end
um saying that this is why she was
giving him uh the sentence she then
delivered that it was the murder of a
young child in her own home while he was
trying to kill somebody else
Andy indeed as part of that crime he
shot Olivia's mother causing her a
significant injury and of course causing
psychological
scars to other people in the house and
to others outside of the house she said
he hadn't acknowledged his
responsibility
so there could be no remorse she said
he's a father and she acknowledged that
he would be separated from his own
family but that she said was all his
doing
a Martin of what happens now Thomas
Cashman as we've been telling our
viewers wasn't in court today the
reasons behind that were apparently
connected to staff from the CPS singing
after his guilty verdict last week
um reminders of the circumstances about
why he wasn't in court and what's going
to happen to him now
well yeah the um the whole thing was
held up for about 40 minutes this
afternoon and it began to filter down
that he was refusing to appear in court
and there's nothing the judge can do
about that she reluctantly had to accept
it and the reason we understand is that
he became aware that on his conviction
last week
somebody within the crown prosecution
service or a number of people perhaps
were singing We Are the Champions the
famous Queen song A much celebrated
anthem on many many different occasions
we don't know whether he was that was
something he claimed to have witnessed
himself but he made it clear to his
lawyer that that had upset him he also
said to his lawyer that the whole
proceedings in his view were turning
into a circus and on that basis he
refused to appear in court I mean he'd
been brought here many hours ago from
prison in Manchester so everybody
anticipated that he would appear in
court but he didn't and that was the
reason given and the judge having to say
that she accepted that but she did say
that she found that disrespectful to her
and her court but more importantly
disrespectful to Olivia's family
he will now be taken back to prison and
at some stage will probably be moved to
another prison where he'll begin the
start of that very very long sentence I
I can't remember anybody other than
convicted terrorists being given that
kind of minimum sentence 42 years